did Prince Harry lie to obtain a visa to
move to the United States that is the
central question which a court here in
Washington could answer and it could
mean the Duke of Sussex is kicked out of
America it all centers around what Harry
wrote on his U.S visa form when he
applied for the Visa allowing him to
move here in 2020. in his book spare the
prince admitted to having used cocaine
marijuana and magic mushrooms under U.S
law admission of or evidence of past
drug use can be grounds to reject a visa
application the case has been brought by
a conservative us-based think tank the
Heritage Foundation it's pursuing the US
government to find out if it acted
according to procedure when granting
visas not just Prince Harry's it alleges
systematic issues essentially the prince
is caught up in a bigger battle between
a conservative organization and the
Biden Administration he is the perfect
case study either he wasn't straight on
his Visa form or the U.S government gave
him preferential treatment